now our final guest today is labour's
shadow housing secretary steve reed who
joins us now from south london
uh thanks for being with us we just
heard from um tracy nichols of
talking about the pressure on ambulances
and it does feel that more widely
you know the stress the nhs is under in
london is really bleak
um in your constituency in croydon it's
estimated
one in 20 people have coveted more than
half the beds at croydon university
hospital are
occupied by covered patients i mean how
desperate is the situation
well it's very alarming i'm in touch
with our local
hospital chief executive regularly to
keep tabs on what's going on they're
doing their absolute best but
sadiq khan as the mayor of london has
declared a major incident now
because he's concerned as the health
professionals are that within
two weeks we might start to exceed
capacity and that's when things get
really really difficult so you know
chris whittie
was quite right to say to people we all
have to behave now as if we have covid
just stay at home as much as we possibly
can because the only certain way to
not transmit the virus is not is to have
no contact with other people insofar as
that's possible
speaking to you about hancock he was
pretty clear that compliance is a bit of
an issue
um he also said that police were right
or he'd back the police when they find
two women driving around five miles to a
beauty spot in derbyshire
for a walk do you think that the police
were right to issue that fine
well it's hard to comment on a
particular case and i don't know all the
details but the police i mean the police
have done an amazing job in very
difficult circumstances and we should
congratulate them for that
what the police need to do is be very
proportionate and measured
uh in their approaches but but you know
i i think the real problem here
is the lack of clarity over the guidance
that we've had
from the government people are simply
confused about what they should or
shouldn't do
and that stems right back to last summer
when dominic cummings as the prime
minister's senior advisor
got away with run it driving all the way
up to
county durham and back again breaching
the rules
and with no sanction at all in fact he
got a pretty big pay rise after that
from
uh from what i heard now the
government's constant copying and uh
chopping and changing one rule for them
another rule for everybody else simply
confuses everybody even in the
you know the period in the run-up to
christmas we had matt hancock
standing in the chamber of the house of
commons telling us that there was a new
variant
of the disease uh spreading in kent and
parts of
east london that was more contagious two
days after
that boris johnson stood up in the house
of commons and told us
it was perfectly safe to ease the
restrictions for five days
over christmas we were all wondering
whether these two senior
conservative politicians actually speak
to each other and of course in the end
boris johnson had to pull back from that
position and we got one day instead of
the
full five but the chopping and changing
the inconsistency
really confuses people and given the
crisis we're seeing now in our hospitals
up and down
the country we need the government to
really focus
on getting this message crystal clear
the public need to know
the police need to know we all need to
know just stay at home
as much as you can and that should be
what the government focuses on it's
interesting you know
asking you questions about fines that
are happening now about compliance about
what the police should be doing and what
i don't want to
diminish the importance of what happened
with dominic cummings you know you refer
all the way back to something that
happened
like way back in last year i mean some
people might think that's just playing
politics
well it isn't if you if you speak to
people and i speak to an awful lot of
people about that
that is people just using it as an
excuse though i mean look we all know
what we should be doing now don't we
we should be staying at home like you
say we should be following the rules
trust in what the government was saying
broke you know the government broke that
trust
and they should be doing things to fix
that broken trust but the constant
chopping and changing
i just gave you know the example before
christmas
uh matt hancock telling us there was a
more virulent strain of the virus
more contagious on the monday on the
wednesday boris johnson's saying that
was going to have no impact on five days
of relaxation of the rules over
christmas and then just a few days later
you turned again now if the government
knew that information about the virus
and i presume matt hancock and boris
johnson do speak to each other
they should have been crystal clear from
then that we couldn't have five days
relaxation over christmas
it's consistency of message that we need
not chopping
and changing of of course you know the
consistency of messages
absolutely you know vital is really
important but
i do sometimes wonder it's quite easy to
criticize the government isn't it does
labor need to show a bit more
leadership too about a way out about
things that should be
done in the future rather than looking
back to the past
and in an interview with my colleague
sam coats this week for example kirsten
said
it's inevitable that schools will have
to close and therefore they need to be
part of the national restrictions
package
that needs to come into place i mean
it's not really leadership to call for
things that are already inevitable is it
well the thing as you you just said
sophie and you're absolutely right the
thing to focus on now
is moving forwards what's happened has
happened
the way out of this crisis now is is
getting the vaccinations out
across the country at pace now we are
pushing the government
to hit the target of 2 million
vaccinations
a week we have to absolutely move heaven
and earth to get those vaccinations out
now
i understand there are issues with
supply of the vaccine at the moment it
would help
if the government would give a daily
briefing or they told us how much
supply of the vaccine is available how
much of the vaccine has actually been
put into
people's arms and in every part of the
country so that we can scrutinize
the situation and see what's going on
the second point here
is the government needs to start
planning now for not just hitting the
two million a week target but exceeding
it
because we need to get this vaccine out
as quickly as possible because that is
the only way
that we can end this uh this nightmare
that we're in uh as a country at the
moment now we've
we've heard this week haven't we from
pharmacists who are trained
to give injections have not been called
on to help with uh
with delivering the vaccine when it
happens i've had dentists in my
constituency telling me the same thing
i've had local government leaders
telling me they are offering the
government
buildings spaces where vaccines can be
delivered help to
manage volunteers who can go out and
reach the harder to reach
parts of the population the government
hasn't responded to them you know
the government said no one will have to
travel more than 10 miles to get a
vaccine well actually 10 miles is a long
way
to go if you don't if you don't have a
car
there are buildings that communities own
all the councils own in every village
town suburb
of this country that could be made
available i'm standing
okay you see it because of the fault but
just behind me there's a building here
that could be available for this
community why the government needs to
start planning now to get this vaccine
out at pace you know thanks to our
scientists
we were the first country in the world
to get the vaccine let's now set
ourselves the ambition to be the first
country in the world to be vaccinated
and move on from this crisis okay um
interesting that you just called for
more data on vaccines that i think we're
expecting from monday so
you know handy that labour's calling for
something that we are expecting
to see if they give what they've said
they're going to give you know i
i hope they do give us full transparency
because in too many other cases
so far they haven't okay um matt hancock
said earlier as well that if
you're a key worker and you possibly can
keep your child at school
at home sorry rather than sending them
to school so if just one of you as a key
worker for example
then that's what parents should do do
you think that actually parents do need
to be taking a bit more responsibility
and only
sending children to school if they need
to
well i think what ma i heard what matt
hancock uh said on that and i think on
that point he was
uh he was right you know if if parents
even key workers can keep their children
at home rather than sending them to
school then that is what
uh they need to do but we need to be
absolutely
clear here as well that the schools are
open for the children of key workers
because we need those key workers
whether they're social workers health
workers care workers we need them out
there doing their jobs to keep
people safe so the schools are open for
the children of key workers
um but if like everybody else if there
are key workers who are able
safely to work from home and they can
have their children with them then
that's what they should do
okay and and just finally you're calling
for the government to scrap
a planned rise in council tax at the
same time of course the economy is
obviously
in a pretty dire situation because of
kv-19
don't taxes need to rise
well what the government said at the
start of the last lockdown was that they
would
give whatever support councils needed to
support communities to get through this
crisis
councils incurred a massive funding gap
from lost revenues
and the additional cost of supporting
communities that the government then
failed
to uh to to repay them so we're seeing
councils right now
in the middle of this pandemic and what
we're facing in this country the worst
recession
of any major economy we're seeing
councils cut services and take away
the support communities need now the
government's way to deal with that
should not be to impose a five percent
council tax rise
on hard-working people the day after the
extended furlough
scheme uh ends we've lost i think uh up
to a million people
have lost their jobs since this pandemic
began already more people are at risk of
losing this job when the
their jobs when the furlough scheme ends
that is no time
to impose a five percent council tax
rise on the community and
one of the problems with um using
council tax is the way that you
raise the revenue is it doesn't hit
people equally it doesn't bear any
relation to
uh or very much relationship to uh to
the level
of earnings that somebody has and it you
can raise more money by a
five percent council tax increase in a
wealthy area than in a poorer area but
actually
we need to be giving people wherever
they are the support that they need so
this is just an absurd thing for the
government
to propose doing and i hope they'll
withdraw it okay
um thank you very much for coming the
show looks very chilly where you are but
very beautiful
at the same time thank you for braving
the cold
thank you